but like i noticed with japan the
[ __ ] there's so many different types
of sweets and i feel like it's because
of the gift-giving culture here because
there seems to be like
a gift for every occasion and
every kind of relationship you have yeah
so dumb yeah
there's uh my favorite example of just
the gift-giving culture that is just way
too intense is uh
valentine's day in japan yeah oh my god
yeah well i mean there's val there's the
whole concept of like valentine's day
which is you know on the usual
february uh yeah 14th and then there's
white day
which is march 14th
the only reason i know this is because
of anime yeah because
there's that one episode in every
romance or harem
anime where like the girl or the guy
she's rushing to get some [ __ ]
chocolate
for the other character the girl is
always like so [ __ ] at making the
chocolate has to stay up all night
and the chocolate sucks but the main
protagonist is like no but it's still
good but it doesn't matter because she
poured our heart and soul into
one week before right what white day no
white day is march 14th it's a month
after so what it is
after yeah oh [ __ ] yeah so so
valentine's day traditionally right
in every other country is guys give
chocolates to the girls girls give
chocolates to the guys right like all
that kind of [ __ ]
but yeah yeah that's that's the
traditional way
i think so i think so but in japan
valentine's day is specifically a day
where the girls give chocolates to the
guys now this is right because i
remember this i was like
six you get like a month to like analyze
their gift yeah yeah right how much am i
going to spend yeah
like yes and then white day is amazing
you have a monster conor gets
what's the worst thing about having
you're both gonna buy a gift for each
other at the exact same time this is why
this is why i hate christmas no exactly
because this is what i [ __ ] hate
because right you have to like either
mind read each other yeah like how much
is he going to spend
or you've got to just be like max 20
quid you're saying max 20 quid you know
yeah so that's great because like i hate
having the conversation before christmas
she's like yeah
we're good we're setting a budget on
this right like this is
yeah that's great i remember i remember
this because because then i i got a gift
and i was like sick
so i can just either not give you a gift
back
if i don't see you again or i can plan
it out what i'm going to give you yeah
yeah exactly
so yeah usually it's the whole idea of
like the guy has to give an equal amount
all
because japan is always like one up one
up
the guys have to one-up the girls all
right just say psych and don't date her
anymore
true but here's the thing right in
japanese valentine's day i i know
because i made a whole video on this
there's three different types of
chocolates you can give really yeah
so there's okay so there's homemade
choco which is the chocolate that a girl
gives to a guy who the girl like really
likes
you know it's like the the one basically
and then there's girichoko
which is a chocolate that a girl gives
to a guy
that she has had some kind of like
you know um
dude someone literally just saw the
apple pricing for the phone
let's do that with chocolate yeah pretty
much so basically like girichoko is like
say like you know if like meline for
example right she's our producer like we
work together so
she would give us girichoko because we
work together like she's
we're involved in her life in some ways
is it ever at a point where you're like
stop i can't eat this chicken
exactly exactly i can't eat this i can't
believe you thought about me like this
maybe
i thought we were closer than this but
like
yeah and then there's that right and
traditionally that's where it ended but
recently
there's a third type of chocolate called
tomochoko which is where
girls will give chocolates to other
girls who they're friends with
i hate this song oh my god oh my god so
japan is somehow
just [ __ ] they've spreadsheets
they've spreadsheeted
it's spreadsheeting gifts because i
remember i had a conversation last week
with someone who like is like the
manager
of like teddy lloyd and miyavi one of
maylynn's friends and she was telling me
about
how she like every time she has new
clients or like someone she has to
manage she
you know japanese culture is that they
have to give a gift so she goes to this
department store
to like get this gift for this new band
or something and then the department
clerk literally asks them okay how well
do you know them
um what's your relationship with them
and then she answers that and then the
next question was
so where are you giving it to them are
you giving it to the dressing room are
you giving it
in the office and like like she
literally had to
have a [ __ ] spreadsheet apparently
she pulls out a catalogue depending on
what
answers she was given to give the
perfect gift this is extreme flowchart
and i mean it's just like dude it's just
some [ __ ] it's just
at the end of the day it's just a bunch
of sweets you know what i mean you know
what this is the equivalent so this is
equivalent to like you know doing those
like personality questions
at the start of rpgs to see like which
partner you get but then after you fill
it out
you have all the options open to you
anyway that's exactly what it is it's
like a [ __ ] game
it's a [ __ ] facebook quiz yeah
exactly which character are you
which valentine's day are you